hola en este vídeo quiero continuar
viendo las funciones trigonométricas
inversas en particular en este vídeo me
voy a ocupar de el arco coseno que se
abrevia al cos arco coseno y lo que me
dice el arco coseno es si considero el
arco coseno de un valor x
esto me debe dar un ángulo theta es lo
mismo decir arco coseno que decir coseno
a la menos 1 la función coseno inversa
de x es igual a theta cualquiera de
estas dos cosas son básicamente lo mismo
y de hecho mi mente siempre que ve una
cosa de este estilo le gusta invertirlo
para decir que pues tienes el consejo
inverso de x pues es el ángulo theta tal
que si le aplicó la función coseno a
teta recupero mi valor
así que eso es lo que tenemos que pensar
cuando veamos cualquiera de estas
funciones pero bueno vamos a hacer un
ejemplo en concreto que creo que ayudará
bastante supongamos que quiero calcular
el arco coseno
de menos un medio entonces esto tiene
que ser igual a un ángulo theta y lo que
tiene que pasar es que si considero el
coseno etc
el coche no detecta cuánto me tiene que
dar pues me tiene que dar menos un medio
esa es la definición del arco coseno así
que bien voy a dibujar ahora mi círculo
unitario
ahí está mi egg
algo chueco ahí está mi eje x
y voy a poner mi círculo unitario por
aquí
algo así bien entonces qué es lo que
estoy buscando pues estoy buscando aquí
tengo algún medio estoy buscando un
ángulo tal que su intersección con el
círculo unitario
su intersección con el círculo unitario
tenga coordenada x menos un medio perdón
estoy buscando que tenga coordenada x
menos un medio así que voy a copiar este
triángulo de aquí este triángulo
voy a copiar
por acá
se vería algo así
bien entonces este lado vale un medio
tiene un medio de longitud este lado la
hipotenusa de hecho este es el ángulo
recto este aquí es un ángulo recto la
hipotenusa mide uno porque es un radio
del círculo unitario y de modo que puedo
despejar con el teorema de pitágoras
para obtener a como lo tengo yo sé que
al cuadrado más un medio al cuadrado más
un medio al cuadrado que son la suma de
los cuadrados de los catetos es igual a
la hipotenusa al cuadrado uno al
cuadrado de donde obtengo que al
cuadrado es igual a uno menos un cuarto
que es lo mismo que tres cuartos de modo
que si saco raíz obtengo que vale raíz
de tres cuartos que es raíz de 3
entre dos así que vale
escribo este lado
aquí vale raíz de 3 entre 2 y quizás ya
reconozcan este triángulo este es un
triángulo 30 60 90 y por qué es eso pues
si se fijan la hipotenusa que vale 1 es
precisamente el doble que uno de los
catetos este cateto vale un medio que es
la mitad de uno y el otro cateto el
cateto en este caso a mide precisamente
raíz de tres por la longitud de este
cateto así que este es un triángulo 30
60 90 y yo sé de estos ángulos que este
ángulo de aquí en el que es opuesto a el
lado que mide raíz de 3 entre 2 es
precisamente el ángulo de 60 grados así
que este ángulo de aquí
este ángulo de aquí mide 60 grados pero
el ángulo que yo estoy buscando no es
ese el ángulo que yo estoy buscando es
este ángulo de acá ahora bien qué sucede
pues este ángulo rojo más este ángulo
amarillo es simplemente el ángulo ya no
de 180 grados de donde este ángulo rojo
debe valer 180 menos los 60 grados de
este ángulo de aquí así que este ángulo
rojo vale 120 grados
así que vamos a escribirlo
el arco coseno de menos un medio que es
el ángulo theta es simplemente 120
grados o si lo quiere escribir en
radiales lo que podría hacer es decir
120 grados
x
radian es por cada 180 grados
y esto cuánto me da pues los grados
cancelan a los grados por así decirlo y
120 entre 180 es igual a dos tercios de
modo que esto sería dos tercios
en radiales es más si quieren escribo
completos radiales
así que esto es lo mismo que dos tercios
irradian es muy bien y no tengo que
decir eso es exactamente lo mismo que
decir que el coche no de dos tercios de
radiales los pi tercios radiales es
igual a menos un medio lo cual de hecho
así es cierto pero bueno quizás ustedes
se están fijando en este círculo
unitario y están pensando bueno pero qué
pasa si continúo sobre el círculo
unitarios y ya llegué aquí a este punto
y me sigo
hasta que llegó a este punto de aquí
abajo este también tendría coordenada x
igual a menos un medio así que porque el
valor no es todo este ángulo digamos
todo este ángulo de aquí porque no es
todo eso el valor del arco coseno de
menos un medio pues la razón es que me
tengo que restringir esto es de hecho
una convención no no tengo opción en
esto me tengo que restringir a valores
de ángulos que se queden dentro de los
dos primeros cuadrantes solo voy a
considerar este segmento del círculo
unitario este arco precisamente de aquí
de cero hasta y esos son los ángulos que
voy a aceptar para mis valores del arco
coseno es decir cuando tengo que el arco
coseno
de x es igual a un ángulo theta entonces
tengo que pedir que el sitet a está
escrito en radiales
pero sea menor o igual la teta y theta
sea menor o igual a pi o si lo quiero
escribir en grados 0 radiales es igual a
cero grados pero pi radiales
es igual a 180 grados de modo que tengo
que pedir esto y qué valores son
aceptables para x qué valores le puedo
insertar a mi función de arco coseno
pues si quiero que el arco coseno de que
sea igual a theta entonces el coche no
detecta tiene que ser igual a equis pero
el coche no solo toma valores entre 1 y
menos 1 de modo que menos 1 es menor o
igual a equis que es menor o igual a 1 y
estas dos restricciones son las que me
dan el dominio y el contra dominio del
arco coseno de hecho si quisieran
podrían escribir que el arco coseno
y espero no confundirlos con esto es una
función que va del intervalo cerrado
menos 1 1
en
en el intervalo cero api
mi dominio son valores que están entre
menos uno y uno y mikko dominio son
valores que están entre 0 y irradian es
bueno y sólo quiero secar rápidamente mi
trabajo en mi calculadora voy a poner
seno al menos uno de menos 0.5 que es lo
mismo que menos un medio y esto cuánto
me da me da dos puntos serán 94 y eso es
igual a 2 peter sí pues vamos a checar
cuánto sería 2 por pi entre 3
nos da exactamente el mismo número por
lo tanto estamos en lo correcto por lo
tanto
esto está muy bien
ok ahora veamos algo interesante veamos
la siguiente pregunta interesante qué
sucede si primero tomó una equis algún
valor de x entre menos uno y uno y le
aplicó la función arco coseno consideró
arco coseno de x ya eso le aplicó la
función coseno como el coseno del arco
coseno de x pues nosotros sabemos que el
arco coseno de x arco coseno de x es
igual a un ángulo theta y este ángulo
theta satisface que coseno beteta
es igual a equis esto lo anoté por acá
arriba acá entonces
esto de aquí
para cualquier valor de x entre menos
uno y uno satisface que esto es igual a
el coseno de este ángulo theta que tiene
la propiedad de que coseno eta es igual
a equis y esto se vale para cualquier x
entre menos uno y uno
ahora les hago una pregunta por puntos
extra una pregunta un poco más
truculenta qué pasa si primero tomó el
coseno de algún ángulo theta
y después tomó el arco coseno
considero el arco coseno del coseno de
un ángulo theta entonces qué pasa y mi
respuesta va a ser depende
si te está está en el rango de mi
función si te está está entre cero y pi
irradia mes
porque ryan es entonces el arco coseno
lo único que va a hacer es regresarme el
valor de teta y eso es porque el coche
no detecta siempre es un número entre
menos uno y uno y el arco coseno es un
número entre cero y pi radiales y es
único así que me regresaría teta pero
qué pasa si teta no está en este rango
si te está no está en ese rango entonces
va a pasar algo curioso primero hagamos
un ejemplo en el que te estás yeste en
este rango esto valía sí 0 era menor o
igual a theta menor o igual a pib por
ejemplo vamos a hacer uno que conozcamos
si considero el arco coseno
el coseno de digamos dos tercios que es
el que acabamos de hacer dos tercios
cuánto sería esto pues coseno de dos
tercios acabamos de ver es
- un medio esto lo vimos acá arriba
recuerdan cuando hicimos todo esto vimos
que el cose no de dos tercios hasta aquí
el coseno de dos tercios radiales es
igual a menos un medio
así que esto vale menos un medio todo es
igual a arco coseno de menos un medio
pero recuerden el arco coseno está entre
0 y radiales de modo que esto sería
igual a
dos tercios de hecho lo calculamos y nos
dio dos tercios pero por ejemplo si
pusiera cuánto vale el arco coseno
del coseno de digamos por ejemplo 3 p
3 p claramente 3 pi es mayor que y por
lo tanto no está dentro de este rango
nuestra dentro del rango del arco coseno
pues esto cuánto sería déjenme vuelvo a
dibujar mi círculo unitario
pongo mis ejes
pongo mis ejes pongo mi círculo
está bien
y ahora
cuánto estrés pues dos pies sería dar
una vuelta completa carro doy una vuelta
completa
y regrese a este punto ya está llevando
ahora me sobra pi así que doy otra media
vuelta hasta que acabó en este punto de
aquí y cuál es la coordenada x de ese
punto pues es menos 1 este es el círculo
unitario así que la coordenada x de este
punto es menos 1 así que esto de aquí
sería menos 1 de modo que esto es el
arco coseno
de menos 1 y cuánto es eso pues
recuerden que el arco coseno siempre es
menor o igual que 0 y menor o igual que
así que esto el arco coseno de menos 1
sería igual a
y radiales porque ese es precisamente
este ángulo de aquí así que bueno la
identidad que es más útil es ciertamente
esta pero en realidad es bueno que sepan
hacer las dos cosas nos vemos en la
próxima